- Today, I want to talk about a topic
that in my humble opinion
is not talked about frequently enough
when it comes to consulting
or corporate careers in general,
and this is what it takes
to become successful
in these environments as an introvert.
So welcome to another coffee break here
on my channel Firm Learning.
my name is Heinrich and on my channel
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
I'm a former McKinsey consultant
so this is where this video will be
also very much inspired from,
but also from other roads
and experiences besides that.
And I want to structure this
video in three main parts.
First, I will talk about
what it actually means
to be an introvert
and whether I am one or not.
Second, I want to talk about
some typical experiences
that you will face in consulting
based on situations that
also really happened
in my career.
And third, I want to give you some tips,
some actionable advice on what you can do
to actually survive in these environments
as an introvert.
So first, let's start,
what does it actually
mean to be an introvert?
And first, I think that's a
very big misunderstanding,
and this is that people
think about something
like social anxiety
when they think about introverts.
So introverts are people
who aren't really able
to talk in public to deliver speeches,
feel super uncomfortable
with other people.
Is this really what's the case?
Well, and I hope it's
not too surprising to you
that this is actually not
what at least the psychology
would say what introversion is.
And the official definition
that you will find
in the textbook is that for introverts,
social situations are
draining their batteries.
So it takes energy to be
exposed to other people,
to interact with other people,
whereas extroverts, for them,
it's the opposite, so they can recharge
their batteries when they
interact with other people.
And based on all of this,
I realized that yes,
I am an introvert and while
I have no problem at all
with giving public speeches,
I actually enjoy it to some extent,
I also have no problem at all
with filming YouTube videos like these,
I know that whenever I spend a full day
together with other people
interacting with them a lot,
I will just feel exhausted
at the end of the day.
For me, social interactions like this
surely drain my batteries
and don't recharge my batteries.
So that being said, let's
move to the second part
of this video, why I think that,
especially in consulting,
you will face quite some
difficult situations
as an introvert.
And just to give you some examples,
and I just want to tell you
some anecdotes from my life,
from my past experiences.
I remember one project,
I was actually the project
lead for the project.
So at my team of a handful
of other consultants
who worked together with me,
we were all based in the same hotel.
So every single morning I was waking up
going to the hotel lobby
to pick up my breakfast.
And there was actually a
project which was quite tough.
So the working hours were quite long.
I felt quite sleep
deprived most of the days,
most of the weeks, and
especially in the morning,
I still felt quite
crushed for what happened
all the days afterwards.
The only thing that
actually I wanted to do
was to be for myself, pick up a breakfast,
eat that, and just try
to put myself together
and prepare myself mentally for the day.
But then of course when I came down
very often I saw already
some of my other colleagues,
of course, from the team sitting there
and getting some breakfast and I knew,
hey, I'm the project leader,
cannot just now sit somewhere else
and let these people eat alone,
but I need to join them, sit next to them.
And even though this might feel
like a very small example, for me,
this was one of these examples
where you're just so also under pressure
to spend time together
with your team colleagues,
with your teammates, socialize with them
even at 7:00 AM in the morning,
but there's actually nothing
like you would do more
than just be for yourself, relax,
and just enjoy your food.
First example.
Second example, team room situations.
So this to some extent maybe changed
now due to the current
post corona situation,
but still as a consultant,
especially in the MBB consulting firm,
so we spend lots of the
time at the client side
sitting in team rooms and
very often, not always,
but very often, the client
gives you a rather small room,
so it's not like you have
very huge meeting rooms
at your disposal all the time,
to the contrary, it would not be unusual
that you sit together
with three, four, five
other people in a small room
and you barely have more space
than something like this,
where you put your laptop, you are there,
then often also clients come in,
maybe your partners come in
who also want a spot at the desk.
It's an atmosphere where almost always
someone will be constantly on the phone
doing conference calls and video calls
in parallel where you
are there trying to work.
It will be very noisy.
This environment alone
for a full blown introvert
is just pure stress.
It is very difficult just to go somewhere,
just have time for yourself
often then in these client environments,
you're looking for some rooms,
some empty rooms where you maybe have
a little bit of space to potentially do
a very important confidential call,
but not always there will be
while I'm sure you kind of
just go there for hours,
just to work, right?
So second situation why
this might be very stressful
for an introvert.
Third situation, social interactions
beyond just the work during the day.
There are many examples for that.
A rather typical one would be that
once or twice a week,
usually someone senior from a leadership,
someone like a partner, is flying in
and spends the day or
half of the day with you.
And it would not at all
be unlikely that then
in the evening you would together go out
for a team dinner to
spend the time together.
And really to some extent,
this is very enjoyable.
Often you go to nice restaurants,
you have very nice food,
and probably more often than not,
this can also be a lot
of fun, of course, again,
potentially also depending
on what your personality is.
But here the truth is also that, again,
very often the days
before, the weeks before,
you had very little sleep,
you feel quite exhausted, you
feel quite sleep deprived.
And probably there are other things
that you would likely to like to do more
than I'll spend the
evening or several hours
at least together with potentially
your senior leadership,
your colleagues, especially if you know
that once you get back,
once it's 10:00 PM, 11:00 PM or even 8:00
and you get back, there are
still work to do, right?
And I can tell you this would not at all
be an unlikely situation.
And I'll try to put
yourself in the situation,
there's the partner who of course
is often a very social person,
wants to interact with you, talk to you.
Often they're in different project,
one project, different associates
sitting at the desk, sitting at the table,
and especially when I
was a junior associate,
I often feel more or less pressed
that I now need to interact,
that I now need to say something,
talk to the partner, somehow
entertain the person,
and maybe to some extent
that wasn't really needed,
but then on the other hand, of course,
there's also this topic of visibility
and how important that is to get promoted,
to get to the next level.
I will link somewhere above here a video
where I discussed this concept in detail.
But again, in a nutshell,
think about try to put
yourself into the shoes
of a partner, maybe every half a year,
there is then the evaluation season
and that partner needs to decide
what associate gets what ranking,
what performance ranking,
which determines your bonus,
and which also determines
the speed of your promotions.
Well, who is more likely
to get their promotion
if the people or if the
different associates
got very similar evaluations,
for instance, from the project lead?
Is it the person whom this
partner vividly remembers
from regular team interactions,
team dinners like this?
Or is the person that in
all these interactions
just sat there, didn't contribute much,
didn't do anything to
just somehow be remembered
really by the partner
in a significant way?
Well, I hope it's not surprising to anyone
that very likely it's the former person
who has the advantage,
which of course also creates
exactly the pressure to
socially interact like this
and then further depleting
your batteries more and more
throughout the course of
such an already stressful day
in consulting.
Next example, office activities.
So the typical rhythm
while working in consulting
is that from Monday to Thursday,
you're really fully invested
in your client work,
needs to do lots of stuff off,
and you're also located client site,
not always, but often.
But then on Friday often it's
a bit of a more slower day,
at least traditionally you
would have had the opportunity
to move back to your home location,
spend the day in the office,
or actually just to start to spend the day
in the home office.
So now every Friday
you had the opportunity
to either go home, spend the day at home,
potentially do a little bit of work,
maybe some office stuff,
or you go to the office.
Well, why might it be a good
idea to go to the office?
Well, of course, because
you meet other colleagues,
you have the opportunity to network,
often also,
different office societies,
office events are taking
place on the Friday,
so this is the opportunity again,
to expose yourself to social situations,
to network in your office,
to get to more and more people,
potentially also network
with the senior leaders
who often also are there on the Fridays.
And again, now you guessed it, right?
So for whom will it be likely easier
to decide to not just
spend the day at home
and relax from already
the very stressful time
you had from Monday to Thursday,
the introvert or the extrovert?
I trust it's clear for whom
this is the case, right?
But again, on the other hand side,
missing all the Fridays activities always
surely is not helping you in your career,
again, we just discussed
the topic of visibility.
And last but not least,
very much related to that
is of course also
relationship with clients,
especially if you are based client side,
sitting at the same
location with your clients.
Of course, during the day,
you will have all types of meetings,
some more formal interactions
with the clients.
And surely this is your goal,
it is your duty as a consultant,
to some extent you're also evaluated
whether you're able to do that or not
to build relationships at
least with the most important
clients relative to
know the project topic,
the things that you're working on.
And of course, in order to do that,
the best people usually
are people who are able
beyond just the very
standard formal meetings
that they have to potentially
just walk by their office,
pick up a cup of coffee with them,
maybe just invite them for lunch,
spend time with them, have
some more talk with them
and build exactly these
types of relationships.
And all of this together leads to
I think the fact that
often for introverts,
especially in the first years,
it might be a bit more
challenging to get used
to this consulting environment
to thrive and to succeed
and to get the best evaluations
to be fast track promoted
and so on and so forth.
So all this being said,
while I acknowledge all the struggles
and I personally very much failed
all these struggles as well,
I do truly think that you
can succeed in consulting
independent whether you are
an introvert or an extrovert.
So let me now share a couple of tips,
some strategies that I
also picked up over time
in order to succeed in these
roads as an introvert indeed.
And first, I want to
talk about just learning
some of these more typical
extroverted behaviors
because yes, as an introvert,
you can develop yourself,
you can learn to also adopt
some of these behavior patterns.
They might feel less natural to you,
it might feel a bit more
challenging and harder to you,
but it is possible.
And there are many things now
that I can can talk about.
I just want to point to one thing,
and this is the so-called trust equation.
And I have created a
video about this as well,
I will link it somewhere above here
where you can check it out.
It is a simple framework
of what you can do
to build trust with
colleagues, with clients.
It discusses several
actions that you can pursue.
And all of them, or most of them,
don't really even depend
on spending lots of
social time with them, chit
chatting a lot with them,
so I think these opportunities
do really also succeed
and build trust with these people,
even with a more
introverted type of mindset.
Second, it's not the case
that you always just need
to do small talk with everyone
because typically introverts
don't really enjoy doing that.
Typically, introverts like to have
even more meaningful conversations.
And here I think it's a
helpful mindset to adopt
that you can actually
derive off in a conversation
exactly in the direction
that you would like, right?
And if you don't want to do small talk,
don't do small talk and
rather move to the topics
that are more meaningful to you.
And in my humble experience,
what I've seen often also the other person
actually enjoys this to have this
a bit more unusual conversation with you
beyond just always talking
about how the last weekend was
or maybe what your plans
for the next weekend are.
And so what might you do?
There's one saying that
that sticks to my mind
that I find quite inspiring
or let me know in the comments
whether you agree with this or not,
but this saying says that simple minds
talk about other people, mostly negative,
mediocre minds talk about experiences,
mostly positive, and great
minds talk about ideas.
So instead of chit-chatting
about other colleagues,
instead of just talking
about your last weekend,
what the experience was like,
just try to talk about ideas.
So maybe something that you read
that really inspired you,
that sparked some ideas
in your mind and what the
opinion of the other person is.
I think this is always a great share,
talking about books that you're reading,
other things like this.
If you do want to talk about experiences
well, maybe don't make it
about the last weekend,
but, for instance, a
question that I always
like that I find always
listening quite interesting
responses, something like,
so what was your most memorable experience
while working at this
employer for the last year?
What was your most memorable experience
doing this or that?
I think that's a great
question also to ask
maybe to a more senior
colleague, to a partner,
what was your most
memorable experience here
working in this consulting firm?
Always fascinating what
types of responses you get.
Or again, instead of
talking about the weekend,
maybe ask something like,
what are you looking forward to
in the next weeks or months?
What are you excited about?
And this is great
because then these people
also start thinking about
maybe positive emotions,
positive feelings,
thoughts that I might have going forward.
Great, nice little question that I feel
can also help you to go beyond
the standard small talk.
Next problem that often
the introverts are facing
is that often as an introvert you just set
a very high bar for
yourself in order to talk.
So you feel like in order for you
to have the permission to talk,
the thing that you want to say
needs to be insanely valuable,
and if what you want to
say is not very valuable,
then you don't really
have the right to talk,
and then you're often just confused,
and maybe even annoyed.
But all these other people around you
then often were extroverted people
who just say things where you felt
like that was absolutely unneeded,
not even worth your time,
but many people do that.
And in order to overcome this,
of course, the obvious
thing is to lower the bar
a little bit in the
sense that not you saying
useless stuff all the time,
but that often you are
very much underestimating
the actual value of the things
that you want to contribute.
So maybe you feel like
a thought that you have
is obvious to everyone else,
which is why you don't need to share it,
but very often the truth
is that this thought
that you are having is not at all obvious
to at least some people in the room,
which is why many more things
very likely are worth to be shared
than you might think.
And one little technique
that I find quite helpful,
you hear what some people
call the barrier of silence.
And this is that often during
the course of a meeting,
the longer the meeting continues
without you having said anything,
the harder it will be for you
to now suddenly, after the
meeting is already one hour in,
to only now start talking
and start saying something
for the very first time.
So this barrier of silence
is building up over time
the longer the meeting gets,
which is why a typical recommendation
is that you should try
in the very beginning,
just at the start of the
meeting to say something,
interact with someone, just
drop a couple of comments,
couple of remarks, even
if maybe they're not
the most valuable ones ever.
But if you do this, then this barrier,
this perceived hurdle
for you to talk again,
engage again, will feel much lower,
much more easy to overcome
than if you wouldn't have said anything
for the very first significant
part of the meeting.
Next tip to succeed as an introvert
is to focus more on your strengths.
And of course this now
taps into some cliches,
and of course introverts
are also different,
and not every introvert
behaves in the same way,
but at least some of the strengths
that are typically
associated with introverts
is active listening,
that maybe you don't have
the need to talk all the time yourself,
but actually you're a really good listener
and you can detect perceived things
while just listening to someone
that maybe someone else who is louder
or who he or she might be louder
might not be able to do this.
So active listening, build on that,
obviously this is a
very, very crucial skill
in professional services.
Second, empathy.
Here again what many
people seem to believe
is that introverts are more empathetic
because they have these antennas
for the feelings, for the
emotions of other people,
which are easy maybe to be overheard
if you just focus too much
and just talking yourself,
use that empathy is so important,
so crucial for professional services,
it is a people's business, it
is a relationship business.
And last but not least,
again, maybe a cliche,
but many people seem to believe
that introverts are also
more analytically inclined,
more analytically able.
Again, of course this
is a very valuable skill
in consulting as well.
So yes, maybe you won't
perform to the level
as other people do in
some of the other areas
where the extroverts are stronger.
But then just double
down on your strengths,
try to really excel in the
path where you are good at.
And of course you can then also get all
the positive evaluations,
all the fast tech promotions
and all these things you might fancy also
based on such virtues,
strengths that you can pay.
All right, and of course,
last but not least,
what's really important
then to you is the weekends.
You need to recharge your
batteries at some point,
very likely for Monday to
Thursday then Monday to Friday,
You won't really have
the ability to do that.
At some point, you should just
accept that if this is you,
if this is your personality,
probably Saturday and Sunday,
it'll be very challenging
for you to now also then just
do lots of social things,
spend lots of time with your friends,
go out in the evenings.
I mean, if this is great for you,
if this feels like the
right thing to do for you,
of course feel free to do that.
But for introverts, I
think for many of us,
for me again included,
the weekend is was often
the time where I just slept in,
where I just enjoyed a slower day
and rather not engaging too
much with many other people.
And at some point you might need to accept
that this is just what you need to do
in order to properly prepare yourself
for then the next rather
busy and challenging week.
So this is my thoughts on introverts,
please let me know in the comments
is this your experience as well?
I would always be very interested also
in some suggestions that you might have
on how to deal with this.
My name is Heinrich.
Thanks to all the
members of Firm Learning,
please leave a like if you
took any value out of this.
Subscribe if you like this type of content
and want to see more.
Looking forward to the
next video next weekend.
Bye bye.